[Musique]
le grand matin Sud Radio
7h1h Benjamin glise Laurence spot à Sud
Radio il est 8h 35 mon invité politique
ce matin c'est le ministre délégué
chargé du numérique Jean-Noël Barot
bonjour bonjour et bonne année bonne
année à vous aussi merci d'être avec
nous ce matin sur Sud Radio réseaux
sociaux cyberhcèlement intelligence
artificielle les Jeux Olympiques aussi
qui se profilent autant de de sujets qui
nous concernent tous on va largement y
revenir jusqu'à 9h mais pour commencer
quelques mots tout de même sur ces
rumeurs de plus en plus persistantes de
remanimement le Conseil des ministres
hier qui a été reporté à la semaine
prochaine l'ambiance elle est comment
dans les ministères en ce moment c'est
une ambiance un peu pesante une ambiance
de rentrée je crois que tout le monde
est est au travail et c'est ce que l'on
doit au français tout simplement votre
collègue au transport Clément Baon dit
finalement c'est dans Le Parisien
Aujourd'hui qu'il veut continuer d'agir
au gouvernement est-ce que selon vous l'
gauche a toujours sa place dans ce
gouvernement après la loi immigration je
crois je crois que c'est au président de
la République qu'il faudrait poser la
question mais vous savez le président a
déjà dit l'essentiel lors de ses vœux
l'essentiel c'est que cette année 2024
soit consacré au réarmement de la nation
son réarmement industriel et
technologique on va parler
d'intelligence artificielle son
réarmement civique aussi une année
consacrée à des grands choix pour ou
contre l'Europe soutenir les les
Ukrainiens ou céder aux puissances
autoritaire et puis une année consacrée
à la célébration et je crois que c'est
très important des fiertés françaises de
ce qui nous rassemble de notre histoire
d'abord l'histoire de nos résistants
avec la célébration du 80e anniversaire
du débarquement la réouverture de Notre
Dame puis la célébration de notre esprit
de conquête français avec les Jeux
Olympiques et nos espoirs de médailles
vous avez parlé des élections
européennes de l'intelligence
artificielle alors justement le
porte-parole de renaissance lex signor a
a détourné vous l'avez vu les les vœux
de Marie Le Pen en russe ce type de
désinformation c'est précisément ce que
vous combattez est-ce que c'est bien
raisonnable et responsable de la part
d'un porte-parole du du parti
présidentiel de de faire cela c'était je
crois une une initiative euh personnelle
qui aurait peut-être mérité euh pour
éviter de créer la confusion de préciser
un peu un peu mieux qu'il s'agissait là
d'un montage ce qu'on appelle un hyper
trucage c'est-à-dire un deep fake je
recommande plutôt les vœux de mon
collègue Fabien ofrch maire de Verneuil
qui a créé pour ses vœux à la population
une vidéo de lui-même fabriquée par
l'intelligence artificielle mais à
vocation pédagogique c'est-à-dire pour
expliquer attention soyons vigilants il
y a désormais des des vidéos créées
toute pièce il ne faut pas tomber dans
le panneau mais cette histoire de forme
ne doit pas masquer la question de fond
et la question de fond d'ord alors juste
il pas supprimé son son tweet est-ce
qu'il devrait le faire est-ce que vous
l'appelez justement à supprimer ce ce
tweet là loxor moi j'appelle évidemment
pas à s'abstenir de toute utilisation
d'intelligence artificielle à des fins
euh de de discours politique je parlais
de du maire de verneux qui utilise
l'intelligence artifici pour mettre en
garde la population contre le risque de
tomber dans le panneau mais il faut
toujours veiller à ce que aucune
confusion ne puisse s'introduire et que
le
téléspectateur l'utilisateur du réseau
social soit bien conscient qu'il efface
un hyperageur doit doit supprimer son
son tweet on l'a compris c'est ce que
c'est ce que vous dites très clairement
je crois qu'il faut pas que ce défaut de
que cette question de forme masquele la
question de fond et la question de fond
c'est la suivante le rassemblement
national entretient des liens étroits
avec la Russie de Vladimir Poutine pour
un parti qui se gargarise toute la
journée d'être patriote et qui courbe
les chines devant les régimes
autoritaires et en particulier celui de
Vladimir Poutine voilà ce qui me pose le
plus problème c'est-à-dire que
clairement il y a une inquiétude de
votre part sur une possible ingérance
russe avec ces élections européennes qui
approchent pour les élections européenne
mais pour d'autres vous savez que cette
année c'est dans plus de 50 pays que des
élections vont se se tenir qui vont
appeler aux urnes 2 milliards de
personnes dans des très grandes
démocraties l'Europe les États-Unis ou
l'Inde évidemment que la la la menace de
la désinformation est une menace
démocratique majeure alors il se trouve
qu'en Europe nous nous y préparons
depuis quelques années à la fois pour
pouvoir détecter les ingérences
étrangères c'est-à-dire la la la volonté
au travers des réseaux sociaux d'état de
venir déstabiliser ou perturber des
processus démocra tout ça conrement
c'est une agence que le Président de la
République a créée en 2021 qui s'appelle
viginum qui est équipé de de tous les
moyens d'analyse qui est armée d'une de
plusieurs dizaines de de spécialistes
qui ont déjà lors des élections
législatives et présidentielles de 2022
identifier une
soixantaine de d'ingérences dont six ont
été qualifiés comme des ingérences
étrangères et dès lors qu'elles sont
qualifier dès lors qu'elles sont iden de
de Russie ou ou non pas nécessairement
vous avez aussi l'extrême droite des
réseaux d'extrême droite américaines qui
viennent régulièrement et tenter de
perturber des élections démocratiques et
dès lors qu'elles sont détectées parce
que ça n'est que la première partie de
la réponse il faut qu'ensuite elle
puisse être prise en compte et et cela
c'est la responsabilité des réseaux
sociaux depuis l'été dernier depuis le
25 août dernier les grandes plateformes
de réseaux sociaux en Europe ont
désormais des obligations très claires
et très ferme de lutte contre la
désinformation si elles ne s'y confore
pas alors elles peuvent s'exposer à des
amendes extrêmement lourdes voir même au
banement est-ce qu'on peut en arriver là
véritablement est-ce que l'Europe sera
capable de d'imposer ses écoutez suite à
à l'attentat terroriste du Hamas sur
Israël et au conflit au au Proche Orient
une enquête a été ouverte par la
Commission européenne sur le réseau x
Twitter qui peut effectivement conduire
à des amendes pour défaut de lutte
active contre la désinformation combien
de temps peut durer une enquête comme
celle-ci une telle procédure ça peut
durer s longtemps c'est la première fois
qu'une telle enquête s'ouvre c'est donc
à la Commission européenne d'agir
désormais je crois que la l'intention
est là pour que la la l'Europe démontre
que c'estes règles qu'elle s'est donné
sous sous sous influence française sous
sous impulsion du président de la
République et bien soit appliqué le plus
vite possible pour que tous les réseaux
sociaux dans cette année électoral
majeur pour l'Europe et pour la planète
et bien prennent les mesures qui
s'imposent parce qu'il y a encore
aujourd'hui trop de désinformations sur
X Twitter évidemment non seulement il y
a trop de désinformations mais les tous
les signaux que que nous avons reçu
depuis une petite année de la part de X
Twitter et de ses dirigeants c'est un
relâchement sur ce que l'on appelle la
modération c'est-à-dire la capacité y
compris humaine à traiter des contenus
illicite et à les retirer de la
plateforme grâce à ces règles
européennes on connaît des désormais le
nombre de professionnels recrutés ou
employés par X pour traiter de ces
contenus illicites lorsqu'ils sont
signalés par les internautes ou par les
autorités il y en a 52 en langue
française c'est évidemment totalement
insuffisant au regard du nombre de ces
conten est-ce que ça veut dire que
directement ou indirectement Elon Musk
serait une forme de de menace pour la
démocratie est-ce qu'on peut aller
jusque
là dans la mesure où nous avons
désormais des règles c'est c'est c'est à
X Twitter et donc Elon Musk de s'y
conformer sinon euh il devra bon se
payer des amendes extrêmement lourdes
voire même quitter l'Union européenne
s'il ne parvient pas à se conformer à
ces règles-là donc je dirais que nous
avons désormais un cadre clair un cadre
d'ailleurs qui intègre la nécessité pour
ces plateformes de lutter contre ces
phénomènes donc qu'on vient d'évoquer
que sont ceux des hyper trucages et des
difake ce n'est pas parce que les règles
européennes qu'on a prises euh ont été
adoptées en 2022 euh qu'ell ne qu'elle
n'embrasse pas si l'on peut dire le la
problématique nouvellement émergente des
deep fake et des hypertrucages les
hypertrucages il appartient aux réseaux
sociaux dès qu'ils en ont connaissance
et que ils sont utilisés à des fin de
désinformations et bien de de signaler
ou de bloquer oui bien sûr bien
évidemment de faire échec aux tentatives
de désinformation par ingérance ou par
par hyper trucageou on parle de X
Twitter il y a aussi le cas TikTok qui
est très important auss à évoquer il y a
moins d'un an vous avez déclaré que vous
seriez intransigeent avec le réseau
social chinois notamment sur le
traitement des données les moyens de
modération on en parlait est-ce que vous
avez obtenu gain de cause à ce sujet
TikTok n'était pas conforme à nos règles
sur deux dimensions la première c'est
effectivement les les questions qu'on
vient d'évoquer les mêmes que celle de
Twitter sur la désinformation et cetera
TikTok comme Twitter comme Facebook et
instagram est désormais soumis à ces
règles européennes très fortes et la
Commission européenne a d'ailleurs cet
automne euh suite à aux événements du
Proche-Orient mais aussi euh suite à à à
certaines évaluations de l'impact de ces
plateformes sur les enfants engager euh
des non pas des enquêtes mais mais mais
solliciter des informations de la part
de ces plateformes pour savoir comment
est-ce qu'ell euh limite euh ces risques
et puis le deuxème sujet c'était celui
de la protection de nos données parce
qu'il y avait de manière avérée des
fuites de données des Européens vers des
pays avec lesquels nous n'avons pas
d'accord de transfert des données comme
la Chine TikTok s'est engagé à euh
conserver les données des Européens dans
des centres données des Data Center
basés en europeope les travaux de
construction de ces données de ces data
centers ont commencé et nous nous soons
ça sera pour quand il y a un premier
Data Center qui qui doit devenir
opérationnel je crois en Irlande très
prochainement il y en a un deuxième qui
sera mise en en service en Norvège nous
veillons attentivement à ce que ce je
dirais que ce ce projet avance dans les
délais qui nous avaient été euh donnés
qui à mon sens à mon goût était était
trop long mais il faut quand même
admettre que la
construction bah ça prenait des mois
mais construire des centres de données
pour que les données des Européens
utilisateurs de TikTok ne sortent pas de
l'Europe c'est évidemment des
investissements qui sont quand même
assez lourds assez considérables vous
parlez de l'Irlande c'est là où on a le
le siège social de de TikTok ouis le
chiffre d'affaires il est passé de 2 à
44 millions d'euros en 2 ans des revenus
qui ont explosé mais pas les impôts de
TikTok est-ce que vous trouvez ça normal
alors je vous je vous remercie de me
poser cette question pardon parce que il
y a quelque chose qui change en ce 1er
janvier 2024 et qu'on a pas beaucoup
entendu ce début de semaine qui est
pourtant absolument fondamental c'est la
concrétisation d'un engagement que la
France aorté de toutes ses forces sous
l'impulsion du Président de la
République avec l'instauration d'un
impôt minimum sur les sociétés dans plus
de 150 pays dans dans le monde dans dans
ces 150 pays quel que soit le le les
lieux d'implantation de l'entreprise et
bien les entreprises seront assujetties
à un impôt sur les sociétés minimum de
15 %. et ça c'est une avancée formidable
pour toutes celles et ceux qui comme moi
considérons que l'évasion fiscale et les
paradis fiscaux sont une atteinte
inadmissible au contrat social
l'intelligence artificielle Jean-Noël
Barot ne sert pas qu'à la désinformation
on voit aussi avec chatgbt c'est une
révolution technologique il ne faut pas
louper raté hein absolument il faut que
la France soit aux avant-postes de cette
révolution il faut comme le président de
la républque c'est déjà ou pas est-ce
qu'on a des champions français on a
évidemment des champions français ça
n'est pas nouveau ça fait longtemps que
la France est très en avance sur les
mathématiques les statistique et qui lui
ont permis de bah d'avoir de l'avance
sur cette révolution qui vient nous
avons des chercheurs parmi les meilleurs
du monde nous avons des entreprises qui
se sont créées ces derniers mois qui
sont en train de rivaliser avec les
géants de l'intelligence artificielle
mondiaux et nous nous donnons les moyens
en en investissant sur les talents en
investissant sur nos capacités de calcul
c'est-à-dire les ordinateurs qui sont
nécessaires pour la conception de ces
modèles d'intelligence artificielle et
puis sur les données aussi parce que
nous ne voulons pas faire rentrer dans
nos vies dans nos entreprises dans nos
administrations des intelligences
artificielles qui ne seraient pas forgé
au feu de la langue et de la culture
française et ça ça suppose d'avoir des
données français no services publics
utilise déjà en partie unintelligence
artificielle ils utilisent bien des des
champions français ou ou pas on on
utilise tous de l'intelligence
artificielle au quotidien et depuis
longtemps lorsqu'on se déplace et qu'on
utilise une application qui va nous
indiquer la route on utilise déjà de
l'intelligence artificielle lorsque on
on va streamer de la musique et qu'on va
utiliser des recommandations on utilise
déjà de l'intelligence utiise des
solutions françaises et là et oui entre
autres mais là il y a une nouvelle
révolution qui arrive qui est celle que
vous avez nommé chatpt l'intelligence
artificielle générative est-ce que
celle-là on l'utilise déjà et bien on
l'expérimente parce que c'est comme ça
qu'il faut faire pour le service public
avant de généraliser ces ces
technologies là il faut les expérimenter
pour savoir si effectivement elle
permett d'améliorer la qualité du
service public et ensuite si elles sont
bien accueillies par les les agents
publics et c'est ce que nous faisonsà pr
a exp il y a une expérimentation avec
1000 agents du du service public euh sur
l'une de leurs tâches qui consiste à
répondre à certains des commentaires des
usagers du service public s'appelle
service public plus et ce que le ce que
ce que l'on sa'est ce que l'on a
constaté après quelques mois c'est
d'abord que dans leur très grande
majorité les agents qui ont pu
utiliser cette aide à à la réponse au
aux usagers en sont très satisfaits et
deuxièmement que le temps de réponse A a
été divisé par deux donc on voit bien là
une promesse de l'intelligence
artificielle générative améliorer euh la
la qualité du service public et réduire
les délis dans lesquels il peut être
fourni autre sujet Jean-Noël barreau
c'est c'est l'accès des mineurs au
sitite pornographique ça fait longtemps
qu'on en parle il n'y a toujours pas de
de système de de vérification de l'âge
sur ces sites ça sera pour quand il y a
des systèmes de vérification de l'âge
mais les sites ne les utilise pas je
dois dire que je suis désolé et navré
euh de voir les manœuvres
judiciaire de tous ces sites
pornographiques qui exposent massivement
nos enfants à des contenus totalement
inapproprié pour leur âge avec des des
conséquences assez dramatiques sur leur
santé et sur leur développement tout
cela pour préserver leur profit mais la
pression monte les mailles du filet se
resserrent dans quelques semaines le
projet de loi que j'ai porté à
l'Assemblée nationale et au Sénat fera
l'objet d'une commission mixte paritaire
d'une rencontre entre députés et
sénateurs pour sa accord sur les détails
qui qui sera je l'espère conclusive et
qui créera un pouvoir nouveau pour
l'arcom qui est le gendarme des médias
et de l'audiovisuel de bloquer les sites
qui exposent des mineurs à la
pornographie parce que je le rappelle
très simplement que l'on soit un
particulier ou un site pornographique il
est interdit en France depuis 94
d'exposer un mineur à la pornographie on
sait quand ça sera effectif le décret à
peu près on a une idée vous savez dans
ce genre de combat armé de de
détermination et de patience cela fait 3
ans que la France est engagée sur ce
sujet la France est est en en est en aux
avant-postes de ce combat j'échange
beaucoup avec mes homologues européens
pour qu'ils suivent la même voix nous y
parviendrons j'en suis convaincu mais
c'est un combat de haute lut la
cybersécurité ça va être un enjeu
capital central pour ces Jeux Olympiques
qui arrivent est-ce qu'on est prêt à
faire face à cette menace on s'y prépare
activement et depuis longtemps grâce à
notre agence nationale des systèmes de
la sécurité des systèmes d'information
c'est une agence que nos concitoyens ne
connaissent pas tous mais qui est
reconnu dans le monde entier pour son
savoir-faire qui depuis la crise covid a
accompagné des centaines un millier en
réalité de grands établissements publics
de grandes collectivité dans leur montée
en gamme pour se protéger contre les
cyberattaques et qui dans le cadre de la
préparation des JO est au contact
quotidien de tous les sites accueillant
les compétitions pour veiller à ce qu'il
n'y ait aucune brèche aucune faille dans
laquelle des assaillants puissent
s'introduire car nous le savons la
France sera au centre de la tenenstion
mondiale pendant quelques semaines l'été
l'été prochain et donc les derniers Goo
au Japon
450lions de tentatives d'intrusion et on
s'attend à des chiffres encore plus
élevés donc il y a évidemment pour les
sites accueillant et compétitions le
travail remarquable réalisé par notre
agence nationale de sécurité des
systèmes d'information et puis il y a
notre responsabilité à chacun vous savez
pour lutter contre la cybersécurité il
il nous faut adopter la contre la cyber
insécurité des gestes barrière
c'est-à-dire être très attentif être
toujours vigilant Jo ou pas JO à avoir
des mots de passe qui sont robuste à à
veiller à ne pas communiquer ces ces
données personnelles de manière de
manière trop facile bref à être très
attentif à ne pas devenir l'instrument
d'un assaillant d'un mot pour ces Go là
le budget de la sécurité numérique c'est
moins de 4 % du budget global de la
sécurité he pour ces ces Jeux Olympiques
ça semble un peu dérisoire dit comme ça
non oh c'est un un ordre de grandeur qui
me paraît euh non qui me
paraî sur la sur les les les les budgets
de sécurité en général on est sur des
ordres de grandeur comme Cuxa mais je le
répète euh nous avons renforcé les
moyens de notre agence nationale de
sécurité Système d'Information à la fois
ces moyens humains mais aussi avec
Sébastien Lecornu lors de l'examen de la
loi de programmation militaire nous
avons permis à Lancy d'utiliser de
nouveaux moyens d'enquête et de
détection des attaques et tout ça va
nous permettre de d'éviter que les Jeux
Olympiques soient perturbés Jean-Noël
Barot est-ce que vous avez désinstallé
WhatsApp tellgram et signal ben écoutez
moi j'utilise depuis depuis longtemps
avec mon équipe une application de
messagerie que je vous recommande en ce
début d'année c'est le moment des bonnes
résolutions elle s'appelle hvid c'est
une application 100 % française qui est
l'une des plus sécurisées du monde qui a
reçu les
qualifications de sécurité de notre
agence nationale pour la sécurité des
systèmes d'information et qui fonctionne
parfaitement il y a petit petit coup
d'entrée puisqu'il faut s'échanger un un
code avec un interrocuteur de la même
manière que lorsqu'on enregistre le
numéro de téléphone lorsque j'enregistre
votre numéro de téléphone bah il faut
que je fasse une petite démarche mais
une fois que cette démarche est faite et
bien c'est totalement fluide c'est
totalement souverain et je le recommande
chaudement mais vous avez toujours
WhatsApp telgram et et signal pour pour
quelle raison vous les utilisez toujours
ou pas au quotidien sur mon téléphone
personnel il m'arrive
d'utiliser WhatsApp et signal pour
communiquer avec mes proches ou avec mes
amis mais pour mes communications
professionnel et notamment avec mon
cabinet nous utilisons allvid euh je je
constate que d'autres cabines S sont mis
d'ailleurs et et notamment mes collègues
de berc et ça fonctionne parfaitement le
mois dernier le service national
universel le SNU a été victime d'une
cyber attaque énormément de de données
de volontaires par an qui ont été volés
est-ce que vous avez pu déjà identifier
l'auteur de de cette attaque ou pas
alors ça c'est une une prérogative de de
Lancy qui est au au cotidien au côté des
des grands établissements publics ou des
grandes collectivités qui se font
attaqué à la fois pour attribuer c'est
ce qu'on appelle attribuer dans le
jargon c'est-à-dire désigner le
responsable mais aussi accompagner les
les établissements en question dans le
rétablissement des des services publics
par exemple vous savez dans ma ville de
versaill l'hôpital mot a été attaqué il
y a a plus d'un an ce qui a eu des
conséquences dramatiques sur le
fonctionnement de l'hôpital qui a dû
revenir à un fonctionnement papier
crayon on est en train de retrouver un
un fonctionnement plein et entier de
l'hôpital grâce à la mobilisation des
équipes et du et du directeur et grâce à
à l'aide de l'an mais ça a pris beaucoup
de de temps il faut désormais et nous
aurons cette année à à
transposer des des règles européennes
nouvelles qui vont relever le niveau de
cybersécurité d'un certain nombre
d'établissements et d'entreprises
Jean-Noël Barot d'un mot pour pour
conclure alors on a beaucoup parlé des
des cyber atttaques on parle maintenant
du du cyber enlèvement est-ce que vous
en avez entendu parler c'est ça été le
cas notamment aux États-Unis très
récemment est-ce que c'est une source
d'inquiétude pour vous est-ce que ça
pourrait arriver en France vous savez
avec le numérique euh émerge un certain
nombre de de risques et la
responsabilité qui est la nôtre n'est
pas de pousser le numérique pour le
numérique mais de tirer le meilleur
profit du numérique au service des
Françis et d'en tirer le meilleur profit
parce que le numérique nous permet et
bien de nous rapprocher de ceux qui sont
éloignés de découvrir le monde nous
permet possibilité de de CR créativité
nous permet par exemple d'accéder aux
antennes de Sud Radio par des moyens qui
n'étaient pas accessibles auparavant
mais le numérique vient aussi avec un
certain nombre de risqu et ma
responsabilité c'est de faire en sorte
de les réduire et voir de les éliminer
dès qu'ils émergent avant même qu'ils
émergent nous regardons attentivement
ces phénomènes celui que vous avez
évoqué n'est pas encore ne c'est pas
encore manifesté en France mais nousous
y préparons Jean-Noël barreot ministre
délégué chargé du numérique un grand
merci d'avoir été avec nous ce matin sur
Radio et très bonne journée à vous merci
beaucoup et quant à nous et bien on vous
retrouve après 9h puisque vous avez la
parole 0826 300 300 place aux auditeurs
à partir de 9h juste après le rappel de
l'actualité